rencontre à présent avec l'une des
artistes françaises qui est le plus
marqué l'art contemporain de ces trente
dernières années sophie calle expose en
ce moment à la prestigieuse biennale de
venise exposé au sens propre du terme
puisque ce sont le plus souvent des
moments de sa vie qu'elle met en scène l
son portrait avec marie bérurier et jean
christophe duclos l'homme que j'aime m'a
quittée et j'ai commencé à raconter
cette rupture
ou plutôt comment elle s'était déroulée
parce que je me suis dit que si je leur
racontais jusqu'au dégoût si je leur
répétait sans cesse
jalel épuisé elle met sa vie en scène
incontestablement cette femme là a des
côtés bizarre catalogué artistes
contemporains une tendance narrative
sophie calle et surtout totalement
inclassable
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il y a quelques années cette femme qui
se fait suivre par un détective s'était
déjà élevé et puis il ya trois ans
souvenez-vous en pleine nuit blanche
elle reçoit des visiteurs dans son lit
tout le temps de la tour eiffel et le
spectateur devient un voyeur se fie à
une vie incroyable il est évident que si
on met bout à bout l'ensemble de deux de
ses projets 11 x c'est un personnage de
livres elle nous fait rentrer dans une
intimité
cette intimité c'est son travail c'est
sa matière première
parfois comme ici à paris sophie calle
téléphone aux passants je me suis engagé
il est à peu près cinq fois par semaine
pendant une durée 3 heures il n'y a pas
si longtemps on a vu se fie qu'à la
venise en invité de la biennale
elle y exhiber une autre lettre de
rupture cette fois ce sont 107 femmes
très différentes qui l'ont aidé à y
répondre
l'aide de rupture sont jamais agréables
à recevoir elles sont toujours
déplaisante
donc c'était une manière de retourner un
petit peu les choses à mon avantage
souvent dans l'art contemporain il ya
des artistes qui sont incompréhensibles
pour les gens qui sont là initié alors
je pense que sophie calle est vraiment
une
une c'est plus qu'une artiste c'est
tunis une actrice c'est une auteure
donkey qui a un message à donner
et la voilà de retour chez elle dans sa
maison atelier de malakoff sophie calle
fait une pause dans ce bestiaire amicale
elle mitonne déjà sa prochaine
performance